[Music]
here are two cells on your screen can
you tell me which one is a plant cell
and which is an animal cell by merely
glancing at them don't worry it's not
that difficult plant and animal cells
can be distinguished from each other by
merely looking at them the presence and
the absence of a few characters are
enough to let us know the differences
let's go through the differences one by
one if we travel from the outside of the
self to the inner core then the first
difference that we find is the presence
and the absence of the cell wall plant
cells have a proper well-defined
cell wall on the other hand animal cells
do not have a cell wall at all they just
have the cell membrane which is also
part of the plant cells it's due to the
cell wall that the plant cells obtain
their proper defined shape on the other
hand animal cells do not have a proper
shape because they lack cell wall the
next obvious difference is the presence
of chloroplasts in the plant cell this
as we have already studied is the
exclusive organelle for plant cell it's
absent in the animal cells now can you
help me with the third difference that's
right the presence of vacuoles both
plant and animal cells contain vacuoles
however in plant cells the vacuole is a
large one located at the center while in
animal cells there are numerous
small-sized vacuoles the central vacuole
can occupy majority of the cell space
pushing other organelles to the
periphery the case of animal cells is
slightly different here the vacuoles are
much smaller in size and they are
scattered throughout the cytoplasm apart
from these there are several other
differences in these two cells but we
will have a look at them in our higher
grades for now you tell me its
classification of cells done only on
these bases are they only two types of
cells
plant cells and animal cells think for a
moment the answer is a definite no this
was just the difference between plant
and animal cells this is not the way
cells are classified then how do we
classify the cells cells are broadly
classified into two major types
prokaryotic cells and eukaryotic cells
here are the two types we're referring
to this is a typical prokaryotic cell
and this is a eukaryotic cell let's
begin understanding the difference
between the two to begin with the named
prokaryotic helps us to know its
structure the term pro indicates
primitive and the term karien refers to
kernel which means nucleus in this case
so these cells have a primitive type of
nucleus
well these cells do not actually have a
proper well-defined nucleus can you see
these thread-like structures scattered
in the cytoplasm this is nothing but the
genetic material named nuclei the
nucleoid is analogous to the nucleus in
ourselves
it has strands of DNA RNA and it
contains the genetic information of the
cell the only difference is that the
nucleoid does not have a compact shape
and mainly lacks a proper membrane the
next obvious difference is that the
organelles are also not membrane bound
that means the prokaryotic cells does
not have well-defined membranes for the
different organelles on the other hand
the eukaryotic cell which means cell
with the true nucleus has well-defined
membranes for nucleus as well as the
other organelles
there are several are the features but
will not get into their details for now
don't tell me one thing doesn't this
look like an animal cell yes it does and
that's because this is an animal cell so
is animal cell an example of a
eukaryotic cell yes it is
both plant and animal cells
can be included in the category of
eukaryotic cells so which cells will be
in the prokaryotic types cells of lower
organisms like various bacteria have
prokaryotic cells
[Music]
you